you've been all over the virus right in
terms of very early on calling hey this
is bigger than we think this is gonna
get out of China you know a bunch of
things that now we know as fact but at
the time you were early to see that
maybe just give us at a 10,000 foot view
like what has transpired since the end
of last year to today with the virus
both good and bad and kind of not only
the events that have occurred but also
the responses from various governments
well so it showed up initially in China
initially Chinese repressed news and let
it get farther than it should've but
then they switched around and did a
strong heroic suppression and managed to
keep it suppressed not only in Wuhan
where's drop but prevented it from
spreading to the rest of China
substantially heroic and strong an
expensive effort and the rest of the
world didn't sufficiently keep it from
leaving China unfortunately and so you
know the ideal thing would have been if
the rest of the world had just locked
down you know traveling from China and
you know testing and things like that
then it would have stopped to that and a
great many other pandemics have been
stopped at that very early stage and
that's overwhelmingly the most cost
effective point at which you you want to
deal with it is just to make a stop at
the beginning but many governments
failed to to stop it from spreading to
the other places now some of the initial
places that failed and then you know
like South Korea for example they had an
initial problem outside of China but
then they did a heroic strong effort and
managed to suppress it there and some
other places in the area did pretty
strong efforts of grabbing it initially
and stopping it like Hong Kong Taiwan
but it's a big world and a key thing to
know about a pandemic is when you have
any sort of growth process when you
average a bunch of different growth
processes the total really is dominated
by the fastest growth process of the set
so
it doesn't that much matter what the
median place does it matters what the
worst place does and when you add up the
total the worst place dominates at least
an unless you could sort of isolate them
from each other and you know mean that
one one hits a maximum the other places
don't get affected so but so it's a big
world that spread around the world and
some places did better than others but
of course the basic problem is where
ever does worse that makes a lot of
cases those people go elsewhere and that
spreads and so that's what we've seen so
far is that even though many places have
done very well the worst places have
dominated and nate'll the u.s. is kind
of one of the worst places we're we're
the guilty party and not over all of the
u.s. say New York and a few places they
dominated the total effect because again
it's not about the middle place and how
well it does it's about the worst place
and how well it does how badly it does
and so you know initially public health
officials when they saw it escaped China
they said to themselves reasonably I
guess that's it
this is gonna go most everywhere and
that's what I said I said [ __ ] I Heyman
said it I thought as it seemed to be
escaping from Wuhan so I guess I was a
little early I was I said look it's
going outside of Wuhan that's it and the
rest of China did manage surprising to
me to keep it down but then it went to
the rest of the world and so public
health people said that's it I guess
we'll have to deal with this going most
everywhere because I like health people
have a lot of experience with the
diseases and basically nothing has ever
spread that far and then been contained
and so they were perfectly reasonable to
expect that that would happen here but
when they've said things like we need to
flatten the curve spread it out so that
there's not too much impact at any one
moment for the medical system and the
rest of our systems then the elites in
the world said no they said no no this
has to be contained so they had suddenly
woken up and decided that even though
initially they screwed up and sort of
the United States
the health officials really badly
screwed up CDC in terms of preventing
testing preventing masks for a whole
bunch of things you can read about how
badly you screwed up for a month there
but then once everybody was once the
elites in the world were concerned about
this and talked about the concerned
everybody said no no we have to we can't
give up on this we must contain and so
ever since then you know that was you
know three months ago the elites of the
world that we must contain and they
started writing white papers and doing
analysis and saying well look some
places have contained you know South
Korea Taiwan Hong Kong and many places
have contained and here we're not doing
a good job but we ought to be able to do
a better job because how could they be
better than us and they listed out well
what we need a lot more testing and we
know more ways to do tasks me a lot more
tracing and maybe apps and different we
need to hire more people and we need
more rules about isolation and we need
more masks and you know people went
while talking about all the things they
thought we should do and all the
different big things if we did them then
that should be enough because hey
there's other places that are succeeding
but the fact is we haven't actually gone
very far in those directions for
whatever reasons we haven't now you know
one way to think about this is to say
look policy's complicated and it's less
about each little piece than having good
packages so different countries in the
world just have whole different
government systems and whole different
strategies and all different resources
and I would think if you saw some places
or working at other places aren't and
you wanted to win your best strategy
would be to pick the package that works
somewhere and just slavishly copy that
whole package I mean that is how
innovation tends to work in the world if
you think you know some company like GM
is successful and you don't know
what-what about them as successfully you
just try to copy the whole cultural
package all the little pieces and you
think you're gonna try to be like now
unfortunately that's not what people did
they didn't say let's copy South Korea
or less copy Taiwan Wuhan
they said we hear a nard
place we're gonna do our our package
that make sense to us and they all
different different packages and now
they're all in different places and even
today when we see our packages and
working so well we aren't tempted to do
a radical let's now go to South Korea
package or something even and then even
that it might not be feasible anymore in
the sense that we might be to past an
early stage where certain things work at
the early stage but they don't work
later and so we still got all these
people saying if only you would follow
my profit we would all succeed but
they're not all behind something so
initially back in you know they're very
March the elites all got behind this
story we're all going to lock down and
we're all going to beat this thing but
they let everybody say well you choose
your own life you choose your own style
and your own everything and now if they
would all say no we need the South Korea
package or whatever it is and all get
behind that and say and here's the
budget and we're gonna spend a lot and
you know we're just gonna do it we would
all probably go along with it and that
might work but we're not the elites are
not like behind one common package
they're spread across a dozen different
like priorities and what things we
should be focused on and they're doesn't
see me much of a movement to change the
overall policy and and after this
initial people we're going down a bit
but of course Lee the problem is we're
not going down very fast so I mean the
two key outcomes for a pandemic are it
spreads and everybody gets it everybody
gets exposed or it's contained and
squashed down to a low enough level that
then the traditional methods of testing
traits can keep it down that still can
be expensive but those are the options
but hanging out in the middle doesn't
get you anywhere and in fact if you
spend a lot to hang out in the middle
you're doing worse than going in either
direction